Taylor Matt wall show a hippie nudist
with a hammer assaulted Nancy Pelosi's
husband inside their home in the middle
of the night but the most important
thing the media wants us to know about
this story is that it's all the fault of
Republicans and also that we're not
allowed to ask any more questions about
it also Elon Musk officially takes the
helmet Twitter and immediately starts
instituting a number of important
changes and Barack Obama takes the
campaign Trail to save the Democrats
from the coming Red Wave an NBA star
shuts down a reporter in satisfying
fashion and another Starbucks employee
has an emotional meltdown on camera is
this a problem only at Starbucks or is
it a society-wide issue we'll talk about
all of that and more today on the Matt
Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Wade has been overturned and this battle
is now finally leaving DC and going to
the Grassroots no group in America is
better positioned than 40 Days for life
with about 1 million volunteers and 1
000 cities 40 Days for life holds
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities they have a larger presence
in blue states with California being
their largest state some former abortion
facility directors say that these vigils
can cause the abortion no show rate to
go as high as 75 percent which is
detrimental to their abortion business
these law-abiding vigils have closed
many abortion businesses in America and
nearly half of those closed abortion
facilities were in Liberal cities where
abortion will remain legal including
closures in San Francisco Chicago and
Seattle 40 Days for life is effectively
changing hearts and Minds in the
Grassroots to end abortion you can check
out their latest podcasts and free
magazine of 40daysforlife.com and
remember that the fight for life is not
over just because Roe v Wade is over in
fact in many ways the fight for life has
never been more important than it is
right now so for more information on 40
Days for Life go to 40 days
isforlife.com
well it began as a strange story it only
got stranger as time went on on Friday
morning we first heard reports about an
alleged break-in at the Pelosi home in
San Francisco we were told that a man
who we later learned his 42 year old
David depape broke into Nancy Pelosi's
home with a hammer and screamed where's
Nancy and a struggle then ensued between
Pelosi's husband Paul and the Intruder
Nancy Pelosi was not actually at home
she was in DC Paul was injured in the
attack before police arrived and took
the attacker into custody
now shortly after these earliest reports
we began hearing bizarre and sketchy
details I mean even more bizarre than
the original story more questions
emerged was one man or both wearing
underwear at the time as some reports
seem to suggest how did Paul Pelosi
manage to call the police
did Paul Pelosi indicate two police that
he knew his attacker how did David de
pep get into the residence do they not
have security what about security
cameras at least if so where's the
footage many of these questions still
remain unanswered or have been answered
in a way that only raises still more
questions
at least that is if you're a skeptical
person interested in the basic truth
that does not describe the corporate
media of course which is why they
settled on the official narrative
within minutes
the guy who broke into Pelosi's home is
a right-wing militant and a q Anon
supporter they announced and anyone who
asks any more questions is a conspiracy
theorist just as dangerous as David de
Pape himself
that's what the media ran with and
Democrats up to the highest levels were
right there with them over the weekend
every left-wing cable news anchor and
pundit dozens of high-profile Democrats
including Hillary Clinton AOC and
President Joe Biden declared that um
dangerous rhetoric from conservatives
had driven and provoked the Pelosi
attack they said it's our fault they
solemnly insisted that all of the
political violence is committed by the
rights and that we in conservative media
are especially to blame
not much was known about
um you know who the man with the hammer
was or what he was doing in Nancy
Pelosi's home or why he was tussling
possibly in his underwear with Nancy's
husband but all they knew or wanted us
to know is that it's the fault of
Republicans
and that's why Americans should you know
vote for them in in two weeks vote for
us they said or there will be many more
2 A.M Hammer assaults by Naked Weirdos
you could be next you could be the next
victim
now
far be it from me to disobey the
instructor's instructions given to us by
our overlords but
I have to make a few points here
the first is this
I don't know what happened to Nancy
Pelosi's house on Friday morning I don't
I don't ever know for sure I don't know
if any of us will ever know for sure
but if the media is upset about the
theories that are circulating on the
internet one of them being that this was
a gay lover's quarrel between Paul and
David that's a theory that's just out
there that people are talking about if
the media is upset about that
perhaps they could look within
themselves to figure out why alternative
theories gain so much traction in
situations like this
and I know they're not capable of honest
introspection so I'll spell it out for
them
nobody trusts you guys
nobody believes anything you say
it's certainly possible that the actual
facts of this case roughly follow what's
being reported by mainstream out let's I
don't know that they don't maybe they do
but what I do know is that there's no
reason to assume or have faith
that um you would be honest about the
facts if they didn't fit your narrative
see that's the problem
if we're getting the facts from you if
we're getting the actual facts from you
it's only because they happen to be the
sorts of facts that you want them to be
what but what if they are what if they
aren't the facts you want them to be
often they aren't
and then you lie or you cover up the
truth or you use misdirection
obfuscation whatever else
the point is that
the proliferation of conspiracy theories
is your fault you did this
you have positioned yourselves as the
Arbiters of information
well what happens when the public
realizes that it can't trust the
Arbiters
they turn elsewhere
or they speculate on their own they come
up with theories
I mean what else are they going to do
just assume that you're telling the
truth they can't
they've seen you lie far too often they
know you
trust in the media is broken and it
cannot be mended especially because the
party that broke the trust that's you
isn't even trying to mend it
now as for me
I find it perfectly plausible that a
drug-addled nut case broke into Pelosi's
home in the middle of the night I mean
this is San Francisco after all is the
violent crime problem in that City so
bad now that even the folks in the
wealthy parts of town aren't safe from
it
sure I'd believe that in fact I would
assume that's the case
what I can't believe is that the
drug-addled crazy guy who apparently
lives in a bus outside of a hippie
commune in Berkeley with rainbow flags
and BLM slogans draped outside of it is
somehow a right-wing militant influenced
by Fox News to go assault Democratic
politicians
that's what I don't believe
to me if the basic facts of the case as
presented by police are essentially
correct then this is a local San
Francisco crime story about yet another
homeless drug crazed freak lashing out
violently
what's ludicrous beyond all imagining is
the attempt to turn this San Francisco
Crime Story into an indictment of
Republicans
trying to blame Republicans for crime in
Berkeley is like I mean well there's
nothing to compare it to it is a logical
leap that exceeds analogy
the real story here again if the facts
roughly line up with the official
narrative the real story is that
high-ranking Democratic politicians are
now falling victim to the violent crime
epidemic that their policies have
facilitated and encouraged
that's the story
as for actual political violence I'm old
enough to remember ancient history back
many moons ago like in the summer when
in armed left-wing radical showed up to
Justice Kavanaugh's house planning to
assassinate him and two other
conservative justices
I can remember when Rand Paul's neighbor
assaulted him and broke three ribs or
six ribs I think
I can remember when a Bernie bro shot up
a GOP baseball practice
I can remember just the past month which
has seen multiple Republican canvassers
and activists assaulted and hit by cars
and politically driven attacks
and this is all to say nothing of the
mass political violence that said entire
city blocks on fire during the BLM riots
It also says nothing of the violence
from from left-wing Terror organizations
like antifa
it says nothing about the threats of
violence that I encounter nearly every
day of my life for saying things that
leftists don't like
you know it's clear to any honest person
who's you know to any honest person who
is actually committing the political
violence and who is actually encouraging
it
in fact in many of these cases the left
actively cheered the violence Nancy
Pelosi's daughter was one of the
Democrats tickled pink over Rand Paul
getting hospitalized
I bet she's not laughing now
or maybe she is I mean leftists tend to
hate their own family so who knows
and of course you know this I must
remind you again is it's not a double
standard
the left ignores violence against
conservatives
or actively roots for it
because they believe Republicans deserve
to be hurt or killed I mean that's it
and they decry violence against
Democrats because they believe that
Democrats are the good guys and don't
deserve to be heard or killed
it has as simple and depraved and evil
as that
and that's also why we can't take these
people seriously
or believe anything they say
now let's get to our five headlines
well despite what the left may tell you
being fat is not healthy this is a very
radical and very dangerous misperception
of reality that's a living healthy
lifestyle is not easy it's hard to get
up and go for a run every morning it's
hard to make sure that you're getting
the proper nourishment especially when
you you're running uh you know to work
it's a practice to cello lessons
cello lessons
if whatever reason you go to those to
wherever else you need to be being
healthy is a discipline it's a
discipline that starts with balance of
nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are the best way to consume
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day their products are 100 Whole
Food balance of nature uses a cold
vacuum process that does preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption on your way to cello
practice when you're disciplined enough
to take care of your health you reap all
the kind all kinds of benefits more
energy less fatigue better focus you
play the cello better consuming the
right balance of fruits and vegetables
every day is an important First Step so
go to balanceofnature.com and use promo
code Walsh for 35 percent off your first
order that's balanceofnature.com promo
code walls for 35 off your first
preferred order
uh well happy Halloween everybody I'm
I'm getting into the holiday spirit with
my pumpkin colored shirt which is what
they told me in the wardrobe department
when they made me put this shirt on
um lots of other people here at the
office are really getting into it though
uh very elaborate costumes that I've
seen the whole wardrobe and makeup
department is dressed up like uh
characters from Hocus Pocus apparently
McKenna and Austin who work on our show
dressed up as a there's a Scooby-Doo
theme going on
um I saw somebody dressed as a hot dog I
think so they're a bunch of other
costumes too and I gotta tell you I mean
I know this doesn't surprise you I just
don't I don't get it okay I mean what's
the point
I think I'm missing some kind of Gene
that makes the costume thing make sense
to me I bet or the rest of you people
are missing something and I'm the only
normal one which increasingly I believe
is the case but when people say well are
you gonna dress up for Halloween this
year what are you dressing up as my
first response is to say do I look like
I'm eight years old
no I mean I've got the beard
um and also why I mean what's the point
if you could explain to me
what's the point of the costume as an
adult what am I supposed to do okay so I
put the costume on
and then what what do I do now
am I supposed to wear this costume all
day why and especially with adults it's
like once everyone has seen the costume
then it you you continuing to wear it
seems like Overkill
because you get the reaction from
everyone comes in and they come to the
office and they see they oh look uh you
came to the office dressed like a
watermelon isn't that funny
and and you got your little laugh now
but are you actually got to sit around
all day as a watermelon
are you gonna go to meetings as a
watermelon
you're gonna go on lunch break as a
watermelon
don't try to come talk to me and have
some serious work conversations as a
watermelon
are you gonna try to negotiate a pay
raise as a watermelon you're going to
have like a Skype meeting with a client
as a watermelon it just I don't where do
you go from here is my point
if I could be convinced on the costume
thing it's like five minutes
if I'm in charge of a company it's you
wear the costume for five minutes and
then take it off
but even the five minutes is a waste and
then we're wasting uh time on the clock
so actually we're not going to do that
at all
I would go back maybe to my Twitter
strategy which is
invite employees to wear costumes on
Halloween and then fire anyone who's
wearing one
that would be a great Halloween
all right
um here's the latest from the Elon Musk
speaking of Twitter the Elon Musk
Twitter takeover this is from Reuters it
says Elon Musk has denied a New York
Times report about laying off Twitter
employees at a date earlier than
November 1st to avoid stock grants due
on the day in response to a Twitter user
asking about the layoffs musk tweeted
this is false the New York Times
reported on Saturday that musk has
ordered uh job cuts across the company
with some teams to be trimmed more than
others and that layoffs would take place
before November 1st when employees were
scheduled to receive stock grants as
part of their compensation citing
unidentified people familiar with the
matter the times reported the cuts could
begin as soon as Saturday according to
Media reports on Saturday musk fired top
Executives in an effort to avoid Hefty
Severance payouts while lining up other
layoffs as soon as um
as soon as Saturday
okay so now Elon says this isn't true
that he's not firing people to avoid
giving them the severance payouts
but it's funny to see the left up in
arms about this as they are
because now suddenly golden parachutes
are a good thing
if the story is true this is Elon trying
to deny wealthy corporate Executives
they're golden parachutes
and we're now supposed to see that as a
bad thing
for years the the golden parachute the
dreaded golden parachute was one of the
things that everyone would decry
especially on the left
and now we're supposed to feel bad for
wealthy corporate executives
if they don't get one
it is a joke because as we said at the
top nothing they these people say means
anything or should be believed meanwhile
the media meltdown has continued uh many
examples that we could cite and play for
you but we'll pick just a couple here's
here's just one this is Amy Klobuchar on
MSNBC
um talking about the the crisis that we
now face because Elon Musk is in charge
of Twitter watch
we have to do something about this
amplification of this election denying
hate speech that we see on the internet
now that Elon Musk runs Twitter do you
trust him
uh no I do not
what uh what's your biggest fear of him
running this
um running this social media platform
well I think you have to have some
content moderation because when you look
at what this guy was looking at he was
looking at just horrendous things you
don't even want to talk about on your
show he was posting anti-semitic tropes
he was showing memes that showed
violence and all of this election
denying uh pro-trump Mega crowd rhetoric
that's what we're dealing with here and
if Elon Musk has said now that he's
going to start a Content moderation
board that was one good sign but I
continued to be concerned about that I
just don't think people should be making
money off of passing on this stuff
that's a bunch of Lies you couldn't do
that on your network nope Chuck
you guys look at commercials and you
decide if they are false or not that is
not a requirement of these companies and
we have to change the requirements on
these companies they are making money
off of us they are making money off of
this violence there's no doubt the tech
companies are huge huge problem in this
and they've got to take them some
responsibility Senator Klobuchar
Democrat from Minnesota thank you for
coming on and sharing your perspective
now I gotta say Amy Klobuchar doesn't
get enough credit as the comedic genius
that she is because that whole thing was
that was very very funny uh and and the
the punchline at the very end really got
me where she said you know people can't
make money from spreading lies you would
never do that on your network NBC
um and I and I did find it funny when
when she was listing this guy and she
was talking about of course David depap
the uh the the uh homeless drug adult
guy from Berkeley nudist
lives at a hippie commune who's a
right-wing radical apparently and said
that he was doing all these he was
showing memes she says
now the interesting thing about that by
the way is that I we we keep hearing
about this guy uh in all of the right
wing propaganda that he was
disseminating and engaging in I haven't
seen very many examples of it
we're just being told that it existed
and that in that you know it's just take
their word for it it's out there he
showed a lot of memes in the global
chart says a lot of right-wing memes
um even though he was a hippie nudist
homeless drug adult guy in a bus outside
of a hippie commune but you know it's
it's it was but also big Fox News viewer
big Tucker Carlson fan
you know if I had a dime
for every Tucker Carlson fan who lives
in a bus outside of a hippie commune in
Berkeley
I'd have one dime apparently
um
this is what they're worried about is
that now there's not going to be any
content moderation which by the way Elon
Musk has not said that he hasn't said
that there's not going to be any in fact
he said the opposite he said he doesn't
want the the site turned into a into a
quote-unquote free-for-all
which I agree with by the way you know
you do want there needs to be some
content moderation
um they're in fact in in some areas
Twitter could do with a lot more of it
right now
when it comes to pornographic things
being shared
um actual threats of violence like I
mentioned I I get threats of violence
targeting me doxing all this happens to
me all the time
and it happens to conservatives all the
time
that's the kind of thing that should be
moderated
so yeah I would like to see in fact in
some areas much more moderation than
there already is
uh graphic sexual content pornographic
content
um you know child pornography on these
platforms is a big problem
and then again actual threats of
violence yeah you shouldn't be able to
do that on a social media platform
to say I'm gonna go kill you encourage
other people to go kill this person put
their address you shouldn't be allowed
to do that it happens all the time on
Twitter
but if you're a conservative and you're
being targeted for it then good luck
getting the content taken down trust me
I know from experience
what we don't need to moderate though
are people's opinions
and it's really not that hard to
differentiate between pornography child
pornography actual threats of violence
doxing okay so there's all those things
that are in one category
and then there are just people's
opinions about things
and we act as though these two
categories are impossible to distinguish
between
but they're really not
I think we all intuitively know the
difference between say pornographic
pornographic content violent content and
just a guy's opinion
meanwhile mehdi Hassan on MSNBC says
that in fact as outraged as the left is
about Elon Musk taking over Twitter he
says they're not outraged enough listen
I have to ask could the Biden
Administration could Democrats in
Congress have said or done anything to
prevent or even slow down this musk
purchase of Twitter I feel like if
George Soros had been buying Twitter the
Wright would have made far more noise
and expressed more outrage Dems just let
it happen as if it's fine for Twitter to
become yet another platform for
misinformation and Hate
well there may have been but I mean at
this point I think it's going to be the
responsibility of each and every one of
us to do what we can to hold Elon Musk
accountable uh I agree with those who
said that it's telling that he did end
up backing off and deleted that tweet a
few hours after he had put it up now I
agree with everybody look I think he's
acted very irresponsibly immaturely
frankly many I don't know how in the
world this guy got to be the richest
person in the world uh acting as
irresponsibly and immaturely as he ha
and erratically as as we've seen him act
not just this week but over the years
but it means that he will back off when
there is pressure and so folks who care
about the truth who care about
protecting vulnerable communities who
ultimately are the ones who are going to
be most hurt by his irresponsible
behavior and allowing these voices of
hate to be elevated on this huge
platform we have to keep pushing back uh
and and my hope is that that uh is going
to make a difference in the long run
yeah Democrats are not upset enough
that's the big problem and imagine
medicine imagine
if a big tech company was owned by a
left Winger just imagine that imagine
how upset people on the right would be
I can't it's unimaginable nothing like
it has happened
there has never been a big tech company
owned by somebody on the left it's never
happened
Hassan says he wishes that this could
have been prevented
so remember all those years of the left
saying that uh Twitter's a private
company you know they can they can have
on any rule they want they can enforce
the rules how they want or not enforce
them don't like it Go build your own
platform
and now you know of course their respect
for the rights of private companies has
gone out the window as expected
something else though because this is
very revealing notice what the left is
not concerned about
they're not concerned
that they are going to be banned from
Twitter now or that they're going to be
targeted
the way that Twitter has targeted the
right
they're not worried about that because
they know that's not going to happen
they know that nobody on the right even
wants that
I don't want that actually I would not
want
I mean if it happens it happens but I
don't want Twitter to drive you know uh
left this off the platform and ban them
because then Twitter becomes a an echo
chamber what's the fun of that
in fact now that we can you know speak
basic truths on Twitter
especially basic biological truths I
want the left to be there I want them to
be there and I want them to be exposed
to it
uh it it it it makes it much more
valuable then because they're the ones
who need to be exposed to this stuff
and it's also a lot more fun
so no on the right we want them there
please stay
now if you leave We're Not Gonna cry
about it but make your own choices but
if it were up to me sure I'd want you
all here
so what the left is upset about is not
that they're worried that this is going
to be a time of a Vengeance and they're
going to be targeted no it's just that
they're worried that the right will no
longer be targeted that's what they're
concerned about
you know I said uh you know we we could
of course respond to the left as they
have to us that go build your own
platform if you don't like it and um in
fact they have the the post
post-millennial has this story there's a
new uh
woke
social media platform out there and I
know it's a little bit redundant because
they're all woke but uh maybe with the
exception of of Twitter now remains to
be seen but there's one out there called
tribal and uh post Malone has this story
on Thursday woke social network tribal
announced that it was preemptively
banning Donald Trump his son Elon Musk
and Kanye West from its platform the
move comes as its creator Omar Rivero
who also runs occupy Democrats continues
to foam in fears over Elon musk's
takeover of Twitter occupy Democrats
broke the news Thursday morning
suggesting that tribal had made the
decision to ban Trump his son and Kanye
West based on allegations of spreading
dangerous conspiracy theories and fake
news it says Trump was banned after
former president Obama advocated for the
ban in the wake of the capital Riot on
January 6. West was banned for
anti-Semitism within the occupied
Democrats fan base the bands the bands
were celebrated however outside the
leftist echo chamber many were quick to
point out the hypocrisy of a site that
builds itself as pro-democracy
preemptively barring those they disagree
with politically from having accounts
well that's not really the point though
that the point is that none of these
guys that are being preemptively banned
from tribal whatever that is have heard
of this platform or would want to join
it anyway
so this is a bit like the kid who sits
alone at the lunch table eating his own
boogers deciding to throw a birthday
party for himself and preemptively
banning all the popular kids from coming
you know it's like it's like him walking
up to the popular kids table in the in
the cafeteria and saying hey all of you
you can't come to my party
who was that I don't know I think it was
the kid that eats his own Burgers
boogers okay
um I just find that I find that very
funny and by the way speaking of
the cool kids I also wanted to mention
this is as we as we look at the changes
that Elon Musk is going to be making to
Twitter
uh there's this from The Verge and this
is another thing that left's upset about
it says now that he owns Twitter Elon
Musk has given employees their first
ultimatum meet his deadline to introduce
paid verification on Twitter or pack up
and leave the directive is to change
Twitter blue which is the company's
optional
um five dollar a month subscription that
unlocks additional features into a more
expansive subscription that also
verifies users according to people
familiar with the matter Twitter is
currently planning to charge
19.99 a month
for the new Twitter blue subscription so
the basic idea is that um
is that if you want to get the blue
check on Twitter this is what supposedly
Elon Musk is planning if you want to get
the blue check on Twitter or if you want
to keep the one you already have that
you got to pay 20 bucks a month for it
which I think is a great plan actually I
say this is somebody who has a blue
check I don't see myself paying 20 bucks
a month for it unless there are some
great additional there are some perks
you could offer that that um that I
would pay 20 bucks a month for like if
if you give me the ability
to just unilaterally ban someone if I
don't like them then I'd pay 20 bucks a
month for that I'd pay 50 bucks a month
for that
um but just for the check I won't pay it
but I think it's a good idea because
the idea about the original the reason
they call it a verified it's a
verification badge on these social media
sites and they all have them
the idea of the verification badge is
simply to verify that the person who
runs the account is a real person and
not a bot that's really that's that's
what it is
um
it's turned into this kind of like
elitist Club you know it's turned into
the cool it's supposed to be the popular
kids table in the lunchroom that's what
it's turned into
and they end up giving the verification
badge to these small irrelevant accounts
people that are supposedly in media and
have like a thousand followers and they
get their verification badge because
they get to go to the front of the line
and they get accepted into the cool kids
club that's not what it's supposed to be
it's supposed to just be that you can
verify that you are a real person
um
and you know the part of the
verification process is you give them an
ID or whatever you prove that you're a
real person and now you're a verified
account
if that's important to you charge them
this is like uh this is a tax that he's
laid that he's uh imposing on the blue
check
Club on Twitter and again as a member of
that club I actually think it's a great
idea there are not many taxes that I
agree with but this one I would because
that's optional
I would just say
yeah I don't need no thanks I don't need
the blue check but the blue check is
very important
to left Wingers on Twitter it's very
important to them
and so they will they'll complain about
it but they will pay the 20 bucks for it
all right
um Democrats are panicking as we head to
the midterms so now they are trotting
out their secret weapon which is the
president of the United States not the
current one they don't he's not there's
they don't want him on the campaign
Trail this is rather Obama and um
the most recent Democratic president
before Biden and he had these thoughts
to share on the campaign Trail this
weekend listen
but these days just about every
Republican politician seems obsessed
with two things
owning the libs oh man we're gonna own
the lips
and getting Donald Trump's approval that
seems to be their agenda they are not at
they're not currently at least
they are not interested in actually
solving problems
they are interested in making you angry
and then finding somebody to blame
because that way they're gonna they're
hoping you may not notice you may be
distracted from the fact that they don't
really have any answers to your
problems
all right I think this backfires for the
uh for the for the Democrats to have
Obama out on the campaign Trail no I've
never I've always thought that he was
overrated as a public speaker but he can
at least string sentences together which
is more than the current president
United States can do so I think this
only it's only uh highlights that
contrast and it makes people say oh this
is what it's like to have a president
United States who can at least speak
um everything he's saying there is
nonsense of course now I'm not a
politician
okay I'm not a republican politicians
I'm not specifically who he was talking
about but I will say that at least for
me personally I am not obsessed with
owning the libs and getting Trump's
approval
I am just obsessed with owning the libs
that's the only thing I'm obsessed with
um and to be honest with you I wish that
more Republicans were obsessed with it
I think we'd be in a much better spot if
there are more Republicans obsessed with
owning the libs
now there are
more noble motivations that one could
have
but that's better than nothing
you know I'll take a republican who's
simply out to own the libs
over one who is uh who's more concerned
about appeasing left than taking the
path of least resistance and just sort
of coasting along and not getting into
any trouble which is what Mo which is
how you describe most Republicans
especially on the national stage
I'll take I'll take the former option
over that
now I want to play this clip for you too
Kyrie Irving is the NBA star with the
Nets he's been getting himself in
trouble with the media
for social media posts that he's been
putting up last year you know he
wouldn't get vaccinated and they were on
his case for that
now he's posting stuff they don't like a
few weeks ago he posted something about
the New World Order quoting Alex Jones
and then more recently he tweeted
something about a film called Hebrews to
Negroes that's what the film is called
um a film that the media says is
anti-Semitic which maybe it is I know
absolutely nothing at all about this
movie I have no clue never heard of it
before I've done zero seconds of
research on it because I don't really
care about a film that I've never heard
of that a pet basketball player was
talking about
doesn't seem like it matters but it led
to this exchange between Kyrie Irving
and a reporter that I thought was
interesting much
okay while we're on the topic of
promotion
why did you decide to promote something
that Alex Jones said
that was a few weeks ago I do not stand
with Alex Jones
position narrative
court case that he had with Sandy Hook
or any of the kids that felt like they
had to relive trauma or parents that had
to relive trauma or to be dismissive to
all the lives that were lost during that
tragic event
my my post was a post from Alex Jones
that he did in the early 90s or late 90s
about secret societies in America of
occults and it's true so
I wasn't identifying with anything of
being a campaigning a campaignist for
Alex Jones or anything I'm just there to
post and it's funny and it's actually
hilarious because out of all the things
I posted that day that was the moan post
that everyone chose to
chose to see it just goes back to the
way our world is and works I'm not here
to complain about it I just exist
and to follow up on the promotion of the
movie in the book can you please stop
calling her a promotion what am I
promoting
put it out on your platform but I'm
promoting it do you see me doing do you
see in front of it out there people are
going to say that you are put it out
there just like you put things out there
right yeah but uh okay it's not put
things out there for a living right
right but my stuff is great so let's
move on filled let's move on
anti-semitic let's move on don't
dehumanize me up here I'm not I'm not
doing that post whatever I want so say
that and shut it down and move on to the
next question but Kyrie you have to
understand that but I don't have to
understand anything from you not stop me
nothing
bro move on but by posting next question
any questions do you guys have any more
questions and they're gonna say you guys
have any more questions
this is going to be a clip that he's
going to Marvel at is this any more
questions but you're not answering the
question there's another answering your
question oh my god let's make another
Instagram clip so we could be famous
again next question
um
I'm with Kyrie Irving on this one for
two reasons well three uh I generally am
on board with anyone who treats the
left-wing Sports media with contempt and
disregard
um and uh just talks over them and
refuses to answer the questions I'm on
board with that I love that I think
that's what they deserve also Kyrie is
right that just because you mentioned
something or quote someone that doesn't
mean that you're promoting okay it
doesn't mean you're promoting something
you could be maybe he was promoting the
film I don't even know what the what the
Tweet was or the Instagram post I don't
know I don't care but he's not promoting
Alex Jones by quoting him
and and third the bigger Point here
which really Harkens back to the first
is screw these hacks you know how many
tense exchanges has the media had with
LeBron James for spreading Pro BLM
misinformation you know for putting the
picture of a cop out there who uh in the
Makaya Bryant case who's saved a woman's
life and put his picture out of the day
you're next
how many intense exchanges have there
been over that
so it's all disingenuous
there's a double standard as always
and uh that's all that's all we need to
know about this
that that that
perfectly absolutely justifies Kyrie
Irving's approach
um in this case
no matter how you feel about whatever he
posted and like I said it doesn't even
matter doesn't matter to me what he
posted doesn't make a difference
all right finally
uh before we get to the comment section
this is from page six it says it looks
like the clooneys have either a budding
artist or politician in the family or
perhaps both appearing alongside
Michelle Obama and Melinda French gates
at a panel in New York City on Tuesday
the human rights lawyer revealed just
how much her five-year-old twins Ella
and Alexander Inspire her work
the 44 year old admitted that while her
kids whom she shares with husband George
Clooney 61 aren't quite on top of
current events her son often takes notes
of what she's up to at work in fact she
didn't hesitate giving his two he didn't
hesitate giving us two cents on the
current situation surrounding Russian
President Vladimir Putin
she said my son drew a picture the other
day of a prison and he was like Putin
should be here
so her five-year-old son is drawing
pictures of Putin in prison
um my five-year-old son has never drawn
a picture of Putin
because he has no idea who Putin is
because I'm not a lunatic
and I don't talk to my five-year-old
about geopolitical events
so oftentimes when when celebrities and
leftists post things like this the the
assumption
is that they're making it up and this
this is all like they're inventing these
things that their kids said or these
political insights that their kids
offered and I think oftentimes it is
made up I think oftentimes it's it is
invented sure
but I'm also perfectly willing to
believe
that these nut cases are actually
talking to their toddlers into their
four and five-year-olds about the war in
Ukraine
and yeah if you sit a five-year-old down
and tell them all about somebody named
Putin and tell them that he's a bad guy
and a villain and he wants to Nuke the
entire world and if you tell if I roll
that that'll sink in for sure and and it
wouldn't surprise me it starts drawing
pictures of the bad guy Putin and
talking about Putin all the time
and absolutely I mean five-year-olds are
very impressionable
and they latch on to things and uh if
you tell them something like that
they'll latch onto it
but so what that tells me is if you're
not a liar which again is a possibility
you're just a bad parent
for for foisting these concerns onto
your five-year-old
what the hell is he gonna do with it
what do you want him to do about Putin
I mean what do you want any of us to do
about poop but what do you want your
five-year-old to do about it
a good a good approach here if you you
know if you're a good parent
is that you tell it's not that you never
share troubling information
with your young children it's that you
only share with them the troubling
information that is relevant to their
lives and that they can respond to in
some way
so it's a troubling fact that if you run
into the road chasing a bouncy ball you
might get hit by a car and killed that's
a troubling fact
but it's also a fact that's relevant to
your child's life and so that's
something you need to tell a
five-year-old
you know uh so there there are there are
dangers and concerns you need to tell
your kids about
but only the ones that they can respond
to the ones that the information that
will be useful and will make them safer
in their in their everyday life
as as they get older you know it's once
you become older that you're going to
start to encounter
um all of the misery and you can become
aware of the misery and despair and all
the terrible things that are just out
there in the world
and you got to carry that knowledge
around with you every day knowing that
you can't do anything about most of it
yeah that's not easy even for adults to
deal with
but a five-year-old shouldn't have to
again if you're interested in actually
being a good parent
let's get now to the comment section
s
[Music]
well as you know I've recently updated
my style it was a controversial decision
but I also think the right move I have a
new set I wear Blazers it's a whole new
me but the best thing about my new style
is true classic tees true classic makes
a man look good and feel good no more
boxy fit or loose collars true classic
fits a a bit tighter in the chest and
sleeves but leaves room in the Torso for
a relaxed t-shirt feel plus my listeners
get 25 off true classic tees with code
Walsh at trueclassic.com all the true
classic styles are super soft and
reasonably priced they're more than just
a t-shirt company true classic has all
the menswear Staples you need including
polos workout shirts and boxer briefs
you can build your entire wardrobe with
true classic
um I love their bundles you can purchase
three packs or a six pack and the price
per shirt is far more reasonable than
any other premium brand true classic has
a 100 risk-free guarantee with a 30-day
return policy the response to True
classic tees has been overwhelmingly
positive so you don't have to take my
word for it they've got over seventy
thousand five star reviews so if you
were like me a few months back and in
desperate need of a new wardrobe check
out trueclassic.com that's
trueclassic.com use promo code Walsh to
get 25 off plus free shipping on
purchases over a hundred dollars
trueclassic.com promo code walls true
classic when you look good you feel good
well we had our 11th anniversary over
the weekend my wife and I
um 11th wedding anniversary 11 years
we've been in this game as is I guess
widely known now I met my wife when I
was an obscure shock chalk morning radio
host in Delaware earning I believe a
cool 22 000 a year if I remember
correctly at the time started out at 17
grand a year so I was there for five
years we you know I made it all the way
up to 22 000 you're quite proud of that
um my wife you know married me moved
into our uh one bedroom 400 square foot
apartment that I've been living in it
was an old house that had been converted
into Apartments my my kitchen was at one
point I could tell a CL it had been a
closet not even a walk-in closet now it
was a kitchen uh rotating cast of
Neighbors that always had a rotating
list of reasons why the police were
coming and visiting them oftentimes late
at night and quite noisily the whole
building was infested with cockroaches
and mice and it was quite disgusting
my wife willingly married me and moved
into that situation
um I remember we had our first
Thanksgiving as a married couple a month
about a month after we got married and I
didn't have a working oven in the
apartment or or a dining room table or
chairs or or anything really no like no
furniture so she whipped up a pretty
good Thanksgiving meal using most of the
microwave and we just sat around in
folding chairs and ate it and uh you
know you look back at times like this
sort of nostalgically
but in reality living through it it was
quite tough you know it's difficult uh
to be broke and barely scraping by
and
um
but we made it through through that and
uh and
largely helped Along by by my wife and
uh
all of that to say
when she suggested a few weeks ago that
on our anniversary this year I should
accompany her to a tea time at a fancy
hotel in Nashville I figured I I owed it
to her it's not my cup of tea literally
but I said you know what
you gave me everything in life that I
care about
I can I can give you tea time and so I
and so I did and we went to the tea time
and uh she she did tell me that there
are plenty of men who go to the tea time
and that it wouldn't be weird for me as
a man because there'd be other guys
there and that was false advertising it
turned out because I got there and there
were no there were no other men and
eventually there was another man but he
was 95 years old and uh so you know and
I was there and they brought
they brought out the little tea kettles
and they brought out little sandwiches
uh with cucumbers on them
and all the food was way too small and I
was hungry and I just wanted a beer and
a cheeseburger but I sat there and the
women who were all at the tea time in
their fancy hats they stared at me and
you know they said to themselves what
the hell is this big bearded oaf doing
at our tea time and I could feel their
judgment
bearing down on me
but uh I handled it with Grace and
without complaint for the sake of my
lovely bride
I did complain but only a little bit by
my standards so I think it was okay
uh my wife made it all better anyway
because she gave me two bottles of
whiskey and a bunch of socks as an
anniversary present which are my
favorite things whiskey and socks so it
all worked out all right SK 420 says
Matt I listened to what you say
carefully I'm 17. I deleted all social
media to focus on football not school
and my quality of life has been way
better godspeed Sweet Daddy
I like how you specify you're focusing
on football not school but you're
focusing on something and I and I
consider that a good thing you're
focusing not on social media on
something else something that you're
doing and that is uh that is a positive
that puts you far ahead of most most of
your peers I would say
uh Ronan says Matt a good alternative to
the word proud is honored we all know
that people these days have too much
pride in things that they didn't get
themselves and things that aren't an
accomplishment
yeah I think honored works like I said
you could also say rather than saying
I'm proud of this and I can say I'm
happy about this I'm I I actually think
grateful is the better word to be used
to be using in so many
um
contexts
but the problem is that as we talked
about you know only certain people are
allowed to be proud whereas other people
it's not just that you're not supposed
to be proud it's that you're supposed to
be the opposite you're supposed to be uh
guilt-ridden and remorseful
um
the preacher's wife says just watched
what is a woman with a bunch of friends
hilarious and terrifying we knew that
there were people that evil and deranged
in our society or who knew I appreciate
Matt's facial expressions during their
insane answers fantastic job I wish it
were on a non-paid platform the people
that need to see it won't pay I totally
understand why they have to charge but
wish someone would sponsor it for the
public to be able to watch absolutely a
must watch well we have been going on
tour uh screening the movie all around
and and I know that there are other
plenty of other groups that have had
their own screenings which is something
that
I would encourage you to do have your
own screening invite people to come but
at the same time also
um
you know
it I know that uh that the daily wire
and the platform that we offer here that
we you know I believe in what we're
doing
I believe we're we're doing important
work in the culture
and um
as we always are talking about and it's
true it sounds like a sales pitch and it
sort of is but it also happens to be the
truth that we can't do this work without
people becoming subscribers and paying
and supporting us like this is this
really is a team effort which is one of
the reasons why you know it's you're not
going to take your content and just
offer for free to the public
um because if we do that then we're not
the platform we don't have the power and
the ability to do things we do we also
don't have a movie like what is a woman
doesn't exist without the subscribers it
just wouldn't we wouldn't be able to do
it we would not have been able to do it
and we wouldn't be able to do anything
like it in the future so but thank you
for watching really appreciate that
um evil Chucky says you can only earn
respect you certainly can't demand it
uh yeah it's it's actually the
difference between command and demand
right you can't demand respect well you
can I mean you could go into demanding
respect is to go into a room and say
everyone must respect me right now
that's demanding you're making demands
um commanding is just your very you know
the way you carry yourself the way you
operate your presence
attracts respect it commands it
this is also the truth I think this is
this is this is true in parenting too
is the mistake that we can make as
parents is that we're very demanding we
could be very demanding but not
commanding
yeah you can make demands of your kids
and shout and yell and everything and
say do this do that
and you could do that and that'll get
you that only gets you so far though
um there's a certain point where if
you've demanded
obedience you've demanded respect you've
demanded compliance for your kids
there's a certain point where they just
don't care about the demands anymore
that's why instead
you know good parenting is commanding
you command respect from your kids by
Your Presence by your example by your
leadership in the home
um and Ashley says Matt after hearing
your comments about Rudolph I'm
wondering if you can offer a contrarian
take on the Grinch where the Grinch is
the good guy
well it's not even a challenge I mean
are you kidding me to begin with they
tell you in the story right off the bat
that the Grinch's heart is two sizes too
small so he suffers from a disability
he's disabled he has a chronic heart
condition and he's been banished to live
alone in a cave on a mountain and yet
we're supposed to just accept that he's
the bad guy and nobody asks any
questions about the backstory how did he
end up there why are none of the who's
in Whoville concerned about this man's
health and well-being
the Holier the now who's have completely
ostracized a disabled guy and we're
supposed to accept that his anger is
unfounded and I mean
You could argue this is a story about
marginalization if anything and it's
inconsistent too because we talked about
with Rudolph who's a deformed freak but
we're supposed to feel bad for him when
he's kicked out of society
and yet the Grinch doesn't get the same
consideration which doesn't make any
sense to me
meanwhile the who's are frankly annoying
as hell they apparently sing all day and
night at the top of their lungs they got
no concern for anybody else it's
obnoxious and inconsiderate and I'm
talking about just the literary version
here you know the Grinch from the novel
I'm not even talking about the the
Grinch from the live action film 20
years ago which if that's canonical then
my point is even more Vindicated because
that really inadvertently reveals the
who's to be not only annoying but
judgmental and frivolous and fake now
does all of this justify the Grinch's
actions I'm not saying that it does but
I think if anything it's more of a
Michael Douglas and falling down
type of situation this is a man
or whatever he is push to the brink
and in the Grinch's case he actually has
a change of heart
revealing a depth of humility and love
and empathy never demonstrated
by any of the Whos
so this it's very much a hero's journey
I would say
I don't think that's contrarian I think
it's just I think how else would you
read the story
well like a baby that sees its father
after he shaves his beard the sweet baby
gang recently experienced something of a
Sweet Daddy identity crisis graduating
from my signature plaid to a more
refined wardrobe was too much to handle
causing outcries of uh well crying now
in honor of the sweet baby games
campaign to bully me into wearing
clothing they approve of and the
establishment of what should be a
national holiday the latest installment
of my patch program that I never forget
about is the flannel Friday patch Let It
Be Memento of compelled fashion among
other quirks in our Strange agreement
where I the cult leader am subservient
to the whims of my followers I'm not
what the hell's it go to dailywire.com
shop to get the patch today and while
you're there get a T-shirt and a Johnny
The Walrus plushie and the Johnny The
Walrus book and a leftist tears tumbler
and a poster you can get all of that
stuff do it right now because I told you
to also
the daily wires post-production team is
expanding as a need of new talented
video effort editors to help with the
ever increasing volume of daily wire
content our video editors work on a
variety of content including our daily
podcast long form interviews and
original YouTube videos as well as shows
like Ben Shapiro's debunked also Jordan
Peterson a host of other daily wire plus
content we're looking for highly
creative people who possess strong
technical knowledge of the video editing
process at least two years of previous
professional video editing experiences
required for this opportunity and be
sure to have your real or work samples
prepared as they're required for
consideration for this position this is
a Nashville based position so for
details and if you want to apply go to
dailywire.com Walsh and click on careers
and finally we launched Jeremy's razors
just a few months ago we've already
taken millions of dollars away from woke
razor companies that hate you and use
that money to better support your values
Jeremy's razors is still the only Razer
brand that actually upholds virtue
instead of signaling today you can get
40 off your founder series shave kit
when you go to jeremy'srazers.com that's
Jeremy's razors.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
during this segment we have in the past
discussed the ever-growing epidemic of
crying Baristas you know there's a whole
genre of video now usually posted to
Tick Tock but sometimes Instagram or
Twitter consisting of Starbucks
employees complaining whining or full-on
weeping about the difficulties of their
jobs
um their list of grievances are many and
varied but they seem to primarily take
issue with the behavior of the customer
specifically the customer Behavior they
despise the most
is that the customer exists
so the act of existing is what they
really don't like they resent the fact
that customers come into the story to
the store and expect them to do things
and when lots of customers have the
nerve to come into the store at one time
they feel especially attacked these
weepy Baristas they prefer if Starbucks
had no customers they would like to get
paid by Starbucks in fact they want to
get paid a lot more by Starbucks
and yet they also want Starbucks to get
much less business or no business at all
pay me more to do less they demand
this is their bargaining strategy
offered to do less work and in exchange
for that concession
request more money
now at some Starbucks locations across
the country Baristas have unionized
around these demands there's a growing
organized labor movement at Starbucks as
of the beginning of October over 300
locations had held Union elections
purely by coincidence I'm sure some of
the unionized stores were subsequently
closed down by corporate headquarters so
they unionized and then Starbucks says
never mind you're closed union members
allege that this was an act of
retaliation Starbucks corporate denies
the claim I have no opinion either way
personally
um I mean I I don't know
all I know all that I'll say personally
is that it is as always
greatly enjoyable to watch a woke
Corporation get eaten alive by its own
woke employees
and yet I must admit that my
satisfaction is impeded somewhat
by the realization that the Starbucks
drama is not playing out on some distant
planet
where I can simply watch it unfold
through a telescope and laugh and then
go about my day on the contrary this is
all happening right here on this planet
in a country that I must share with
those involved
that's what makes it in the end less
funny and a bit more terrifying
especially when you consider videos like
this one which just went viral over the
weekend watch
people wonder why we need a union at
Starbucks and I
I am literally about to quit like I I
don't know if I'm gonna do it but like I
really want to I almost walked out today
and I'm crying in the back room right
now and I must cut on the floor it's
just
like a full-time student I get scheduled
for 25 hours a week and then on weekends
they scheduled me the entire day open to
close up on the schedule for eight and a
half hours
both Saturday and Sunday I'm like three
and a half hours into my shift there's
so many customers and we have four
people on the floor all day
only five people were put on the
schedule and somebody had to call out
and there are four people running the
whole store and there's so many
customers and there's possibly scheduled
five people
we only have 13 people employed at this
store and there's and there's so many
customers
good
I have to say this Blair Witch Project
reboot is pretty lame uh the Barista
this video is a a union activist who
goes by the name Evan this is also an
Ivy league student apparently which I'm
sure comes as no surprise these days
when you see someone curled up on the
floor trembling in fear muttering
there's so many customers over and over
again like a trauma victim the first
thing you think is that it must be an
Ivy league student but we haven't yet
heard the whole sob story because
there's more to it
let's continue
we don't have Fair scheduling managers
don't care about us our manager was
supposed to come in this weekend and he
took himself off the schedule so he
wouldn't be able to be held accountable
for calling out he just literally poured
on the schedule that he was scheduled on
and put up a new schedule where he wins
on the schedule also he couldn't have
even seen that he was scheduled in the
first place because he didn't want to be
held accountable for not wanting to come
in
they don't want to help us
we need a union because this can't
happen this can't happen we need Fair
scheduling we need managers to hold
themselves accountable for helping their
workers they refuse to turn mobile
orders off we need the Liberty to be
able to do that because there's so many
mobile orders and I need to get through
all of them and then people are yelling
at me because I don't have their orders
ready because they don't know what to do
and the customer was misgendering me
today like really badly I didn't have
their order ready and so they were just
like totally talking to each other and
they're like she's clearly incompetent I
have a full
beard
I don't get accommodations for being
neurodivergent I don't
I can't like people get mad at me facing
my sick time I don't even know what to
do anymore
Emily got my Woods up with this job
I really am
okay a few things here first of all
having a mustache doesn't mean you're
not a woman trust me I know I've I've
been to the women's March second I'm not
going to judge people simply for whining
about their jobs we all whine about our
jobs sometimes but there is a time and
place and context for everything and
whining to the internet while still at
your job during your shift in the middle
of a rush is neither the correct time
nor the correct context nor the correct
place in fact there is no correct time
place or context to air your complaints
about your job publicly if you have a
problem with your schedule talk to your
manager
if you need to vent talk to a friend or
to your mom
or another employee when you're both off
the clock venting to the entire world is
never a good idea
the public can't help you with your
problem we don't know you we aren't your
friend
and our Sympathy for the plight of a
stranger can only be stretched so far
for many of us given that we have real
stresses and real responsibilities in
our lives sympathizing with a grown
adult having a temper tantrum because
she has to work eight hours pouring
coffee is well beyond our emotional
reach
you know I frequently put in 10 or 11
hours a day hour days and then I come
home to help care for my four children
soon to be six
but you're not gonna see me huddled back
in the storage closet filming a
teary-eyed selfie video and complaining
about my stresses because I have
self-respect and also because I realize
that there are great many people in this
world who have much harder lives than I
do
I only cry on camera when I'm not giving
a big stuffed animal that I'm owed but
that's totally different
now
this video would not be worth commenting
on if it was just representing a sort of
isolated issue if it was just this one
Barista crying about having to work a
basic eight hour shift I wouldn't be
worried about the video and if extended
Beyond this one individual but was
relegated only to Starbucks Baristas
we'd still probably be better off
ignoring it but unfortunately this
represents a society-wide problem there
are great many people in this country
who share this person's attitude and to
be clear the Troublesome attitude is not
simply that they don't want to work I
mean nobody really wants to work almost
all of us would take a billion dollars
and spend the rest of our lives on
vacation if that option was presented to
us I have no issue with people who wish
they didn't have to put in the work
I wish for a lot of things that are
unreasonable or impossible
I'm about to have two newborns in my
house again I wish that they're both
gonna sleep soundly through the night
from the moment that they're born
I wish that my kids would keep their
rooms spotlessly clean I wish that we
could walk out the door without having
to look around frantically for
somebody's lost shoe or jacket
I wish for many things
if I ever gain access to a magical genie
I will have a whole laundry list of
wishes ready to go but until that day
arrives
I accept that things are not exactly how
I want them to be and I carry on with my
life and I fulfill my responsibilities
anyway this is the key to adulthood
in fact this is adulthood
it is what being an adult is all about
you must develop the ability to function
and thrive in environments that are not
specifically set up to satisfy your
every desire and whim
you must be able to cope with
frustration and succeed in spite of it
and through it being an adult in the
real world is to be constantly thrust
into situations where things are not
going exactly how you want them to go
and there's more stress than you would
like
and yet carrying on anyway and finding a
way to turn even unfortunate
circumstances to your advantage in
pursuit of your goals
the problem is that we've built a
society filled with people who cannot
handle any amount of frustration at all
they can't carry on let alone Thrive
they collapse and they melt into a
puddle
and rather than than converting
frustration into opportunity which is
what successful people do
they look to convert everything into
pity
because that's the only currency they're
interested in collecting
and the fundamental issue is that while
while nobody wants to work
these people actually think that they
shouldn't have to they don't just wish
for the magical genie they think that
the world owes it to them
and when the world doesn't give them
what they believe they're owed they only
cave into themselves even farther
feeling not only sorry for themselves
but also aggrieved
as though the very realities of human
existence are an attack on them
personally
you cannot function as an adult this way
and if too many people in a society have
this attitude soon Society can no longer
function
that's what we're facing now
and it's why I must say to Evan the ivy
league barista
crying in the storage room
you are today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]